yes high pitch tomorrow i have i have
two things going on
i have a colonoscopy and an endoscopy
tomorrow and how do we get tickets to
that
yeah because i envy the doctor who gets
to roll you over on your side and stick
[ __ ] up your ass i i ca
i can't imagine is he doing the prep
well yes i'm doing the prep but i have
the big day 12.
this is my big day toilet i want to see
you shoot water up your ass go ahead
all right you hear it
yeah that's the water going in your
[ __ ] oh my god what's that
showing us his belly and his ass
i don't know first of all you have to
avoid solid food for 24 hours do you
know that yes i do you can't eat the
whole day
right you gonna do that yes i can okay
what do they do with the colonoscopy
they take a camera and they stick it up
your ass
which would be unbearable if you were
awake but because you're asleep you feel
nothing
you're relaxed and then when you wake up
you suddenly you're sitting in a chair
although i don't know who the hell's
going to lift you into a chair
and then on your chair they have like a
little pad down on the chair because
there's always a little bit of dude
because after five per day i use baby
wipes and i see nothing
behind me because i hope my ass is
always clean
they'll be so happy with me i have no i
have that and i have my endoscopy too
tomorrow at the same time
you're kidding you're going to go up
your ass and down your throat
yes it's like bringing a car in for
service
jesus i never heard of that did you hear
that porn
yeah imagine him chris can you imagine
him nude
on the table completely nude there's a
camera up
his ass and there's a big pipe going
down his throat he's getting spit
roasted
like an orgy you know what i love i love
that the smartest kid from my high
school probably is going to end up
sticking pipes up
eric's ass and having to take a look at
[Music]
that